حماوه السباق الانتخابي في الاسكا قسمت
صفا الجمهوريين انفسهم في اكبر الولايات
الامريكيه واكثرها بروده وجددت صراعا لم
يهدا بين الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
وزعيم الاقليه بمجلس الشيوخ متماكونل بشكل
غير مباشر هذه المره فازمه الفيل الاحمر
هناك اكثر تعقيدا مع دخول الحزب الجمهوري
الانتخابات النصفيه بمرشحتين اثنتين عن
مقعد الاسكا بمجلس الشيوخ ولهما سنه
الحاليه لزمور كاوسكي التي تحاول انتاعه
ولايه رابعه الجمهوريه
وثانيا بالرئيس السابق الذي يدعمها
بتسير حمله الناشطه ضد مركز بعد تصويطها
لادانته على خلفيه اقتحام انصاره للكونغرس
وسخريتها من مواصفه جمهوريون حينها
بالتجمع السياحي
والمشاركه بحملته واعلانات هجوميه على
الشباكه وصفت بالمثيره للانقسام والمضلله
فالاعلانات اتهامتها بالاحتيال وهدري ام
والده فعل الضرائب ما دفع الجمهوريين
لانتقاد استهداف مكان لمرشحتهم المعتمده
في السباق ولومه على تقديم الدعم المالي
لمنافستها من خلال صندوق القياده بمجلس
الشيوخ
ساعتين معنا هومز
تقديم مرشحتين واكثر عن الحزب نفسه للوصول
للانتخابات العامه خاصيه يتميز بها نظام
التصويت في الاسكا الذي يطيح للناخبين
ترتيب المرشحين في مجلس الشيوخ حسب
الافضليه